I want to start this podcast with a
question and I want to know what Motel
did you snip the drapes from to make
those shorts huh I'm not mad at him
will I'm a gnome at all those some nice
it's got the biggest legs and the
biggest cab biggest legs I've ever seen
my life well it's like I always say with
regard to fashion never be afraid to
introduce color I don't like really had
that yeah and I'm sure the seasons are
turning you decided to bust out the
shorts now yeah but well in my native
Canada it is of course Pinter it's a
cross between fall and winter and winter
winter and you'll wear shorts inventor
won't you I wore shorts growing up all
year round I would walk to school in
shorts in February
I'll [ __ ] swim in February I'll kick
your [ __ ] head in in February
I'll take you to Saskatchewan and grind
your face along the glassy frozen grass
have you ever played full-contact
football in the winter in Canada on
grass vulgar God the coal cuts right
through me and I don't do well with
contact sports with big guys yeah it's
like it's like it's like like that Annie
Lennox song walking on broken glass I
once dude what's up I think last time
you're here will you guys did a
10-minute podcast reunion we did was
gone yeah yeah yeah I feel like haven't
seen you in seven years dude I haven't
seen you about in since the 90s the 90s
yeah this whole PC thing am i right say
the c-word say - see we're on your
podcast ruin everything actually outside
of any British person I love the way you
say it thank you you're the best at
saying as I say it aggressively no
because you go the the British can get
away with it right you can say anything
yeah they they use the F word the F word
to describe cigarettes
and we're not saying yeah I grew up
around that my grandmother Lee family's
English Michael say the f-word so I when
people take offense to it now I'm like
well yeah hey how come are afraid to say
the word when there's no cruel intent
behind it there's intent matter I just
don't like saying at all I don't want
someone Baek come on now words words
carry words carry power you [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay see I'm not I'm not one of them you
but you got a little uncomfortable you
made one of these Hey
everyone got quiet in the room yeah
everyone got quiet except for this yeah
but those are fighting words from where
at where I come from where I don't know
Cuba wait listen from in Sicily those
are those are fighting words you're not
from Sicily you were born in on a ship
somewhere I'll tell you what I'll tell
you why there's a there's a problem with
what you're saying because I'm sitting
here and I'm breathing totally normally
and I'm not feeling intimidated at all
as a matter of fact and the reason for
that is when I called you that horrible
word you went all right man yo I've
already shown your cards no I'm just not
in the fight mode right now but we're
we're I don't come from I don't you know
I have I have my everybody has their
line and if you cross it every day say
every man has a line yeah most for most
minutes thee it's the front door of
their house me line goes a little
further than my front door oh yeah yeah
like what well there's a certain things
that I would like if I had to fight you
I'd lose quickly there's certain things
the lines a little bit further back but
me and will yeah but just know that just
know that even though I'd lose quickly
with you I'd meet you halfway if I had
to if you crossed a certain line you do
watch Game of Thrones yeah yeah you
watch Game of Thrones yeah you're seeing
the big guy when he fights that guy and
just [ __ ] take his hangers couch that's
what we'll do to you and I pay will ya I
pay hard cold cash if you could do that
to Brian
Tom [ __ ] no if that's something you're
into me good sweet helmet until until it
until I died hunter tiller until it
snapped like a [ __ ] like me you're
trying to open a walnut like a jar of
marmalade yeah I'll tell you this much
it would it might take me a while yeah
if I really leaned on it yeah get my
body on your weight bro you're gonna
fall unconscious at some point
in the first 30 seconds I don't have to
worry about you sperm pressure just head
pressure just by just my palms of my
hands the heels of my hands on your
temple I will say I was one of those
deep knockout snores
one of those ugly [ __ ] oh man he's
been sleeping has he been sleeping 14
hours or yeah is that a trucker trying
to clear his throat well this is what I
would do what I would probably not die I
would make a recovery
I would then find a way to work my way
up the penal system as an administrator
until I became a warden and you sue the
[ __ ] out of dope I'd become a warden of
a prison then I would frame you in
earthy in the place that I was the
warden mm-hmm you would go to jail
No now listen yeah and then I'd have you
walked out but I'd have a couple of
sadistic guards but we'd walk you out
and tie you to a post run a train on him
no no no no no no I find guys to run a
train on him and he's you know he's a
good-looking man but not to other men
you know what I mean these are true and
that is true in prison he is a eyeli I
don't agree with Dave
why not know this I have some big dude
Oh keep it I don't want to run a train
on him cuz I'd have to organize that and
I can't find there only so many Chin's
out there that you know that are in
Jessup black right so I was always the
amount the small amount of gay men who
would have a crush on me when he used to
work out at Gold's Hollywood and a
friend of mine cuz you're not there what
would say every once in a while he would
say I know someone has a crush on you
and I'd say oh who you know and then
he'd say that guy over there and I'd be
like I'm I'm at his [ __ ] league you
know what I mean yeah that it wasn't
very often you know I'd be like I want
more gay attention well anyway what were
you talking about hurt your feeling I
had I was doing tricep to pull-downs at
Gold's Gym right on Cole and a guy
behind me I didn't even know him goes
get your get your hips under there and
he bumped my knees with his knees and
sustar doesn't get those elbows in I
didn't know him and he was behind me and
he was sick rubbing a nitro serum I've
never left never been like that that I
ran away after that set out a gay guy
come up to me and go do you want to get
a juice oh that's no shirt on man
is that on juice I know what you
probably went now I'm good man you know
it
all set man now I do not that up
approval point yeah
how easy it is to get you off of your
point no I appreciate that
because all I talk about is going to the
gym and and a guy well I don't so so
barring going to Gold's and finding a
couple of those scrubs who would
actually train you
instead of that I would have these two
sadistic guards walk you out
title post and I'd have a take a wet
rope I'd soak a rope overnight mm-hmm
thick coarse rope in oil
no it'd have to be water and I tie that
rope around your head okay mm a band
around your head and what happens in the
Sun is that rope would then start yeah
it start to dry and as it dries it would
tighten ever so slowly there's no plot
of Passion of Christ well it may as well
be because there's nothing more painful
and it would drive you mad that my it
would be slowly tightening and I would
watch you from the window they've got
seven years but yes I sit to be one way
oh it doesn't take too long take a while
it's it's a famous torture well I tell
you what would I'll tell you what would
take a while because and everyone's
gonna find out about this because we're
gonna sell tickets and we're gonna have
a pay-per-view it's gonna be the first
fighter in the kid pay-per-view you're
venturing into new lands and you want to
make some real [ __ ] money yeah yeah
we're gonna do a pay-per-view and it's
gonna be you and me and it's gonna be
we're gonna incorporate a little of the
you know the the wrestling sports
entertainment thing we're gonna say that
it's a No Disqualification match right
but MMA rules No Disqualification and
submission or knockout only okay and
then and then you're gonna come at me
with whatever what's it going to be I'm
gonna shock and I'm gonna and I got
considered right and I'm gonna I'm gonna
swap those away and bat my eyes and it's
not gonna be fun to watch right on TV
he's never fought what the foe which is
gonna be even more embarrassing when I
actually do get ahold of you and just
kick your legs out from under you and
then I start the game line the press
yeah bring that up chin that Game of
Thrones scene well what's the guy's name
Mountain the mountain man everyone's
gonna man with hands people are gonna go
get popcorn and hot dogs cuz it's gonna
take about four hours of me just gonna
and again you're
cold in the first 30 seconds and then at
around the four hour mark you're just
gonna hear and then you're gonna get
views Doha laps in numbers no it would
be perverse is the mountain rollin the
exact eye pictures now you got
fast-forward cuz it's showing the whole
scene here we're even gonna do it like
outdoors like this you've gone it at the
Greek theater it here in LA yeah I'm us
and I'm gonna sit on top and I'm also
gonna rent a small person to play with
you know when it comes gonna sit there
like the Emperor yes and just do the
thumbs up thumbs down yes when it comes
to swordplay there we go doesn't much
matter size of the sword matters
so there's Brian with that shitty bowl
cut and then here's will oh goes all
your teeth and then here's will and this
will take four hours with this imagine
this for four hours I gotta watch this
show now here's will doing this and Dad
oh and dad Game of Thrones style Will
Sasso Bryan Callen oh that's gonna sell
paper views well died though and then he
died yeah yeah your wait see I'm the old
rich dude that love you know that's me
right there and then we'll rent the
small guy fine and you dropped that
outfit yeah is that [ __ ] John
Varvatos then we'll hire just some dime
piece yeah look at that quilted was that
quilted armor and yeah see that won't
happen do you I'm not cool having my
hair gonna have to fill out some papers
before we start I'll tell you that right
now you might want to get your issues in
order I'm not gonna get your banking in
order might want to fill it you might
want to get that will going now I'm not
doing it I'm to think about though bro
nothing to think about
have you ever had something to think
about those have you ever had a guy get
your fingers in my face I had a man who
was my friend who basically this is the
beginning of every bryan callen style
yeah I have a friend
I have a guy who's my friend okay no
Lucien worry 2500 no everybody means
he's been three times you should hold
who managed the copper heard of that
before trip in New York City okay
who's a wonderful man gave me my first
stage time in a hurry close to him and
he had a terrible disease called
scleroderma and he was dying and he said
to me I was in and he said well I said I
know I said he goes I don't have much
time you know because we were out for
Lobster and I went oh and he said I said
no you never said no that and he said
that he said oh good oh good good reason
I say that is because he was a peculiar
man who said I was always at a table
that knocked the [ __ ] out snore okay so
I'm sorry Durazo gentleman in time he
said dishonor his memory by talking
about with the [ __ ] he ordered okay but
he was said I've always been a lobster
I've always been a tail man now I'm a
claw man I thought that was interesting
I said okay mom Nelly said he said my
doctor told me to get my things in order
okay now now we're cooking now you okay
with gal we're doing it now you tell him
stone I didn't know what to say and I
said I said here is a man dying and I
said I Lane Lee said you know doctors
are wrong all the time
oh gee and he said not in this case oh
yeah it must've been bad bad and then
will the of you friends of diverse
thinking tell us about those situations
no no I don't know I don't know what do
you say no you just you just send up
that [ __ ] Hallmark card that says
hang in there and never stop fighting
shows the Frog choking out the seagull
you seen that no they love that dude my
dad loved that my anyone who's dealing
with death
they love that dude never stop fighting
it shows shows a frog in the mouth he's
choking them all my father had the best
my father I call my dad my buddies
unfortunately died of pancreatic cancer
but when he had an I call my father my
father's friend is an expert I say my
buddy's got pancreatic cancer and I know
your friend is an expert and my father
said oh he just found out angry I guess
well and I said but he's got about two
years and my father said now he doesn't
have two years got months I said what do
mean he goes maybe three months tops
and I said no no but yeah the doctor
when he was stopped because stop stop
stop he's got I'm just telling you if if
they found it it's okay
and I go well that seems kind of harsh
and I was calling him trying to get some
good news and he goes now you gotta say
bye now
and he was right he was right died two
months later really yeah and he hit me
with this so he goes he goes he goes I
hate to be insensitive it's just that
I'm reading about World War two and the
Battle of the and he goes through the
battle where like literally was it
happened literally in in an in in a day
like a hundred thousand young men fell
sure and all
well that puts things in perspective yes
all right I gotta go yeah if the the
frogs versus the seagulls no fraud
you've never seen that either you're
joking right now you've never seen that
card it's a famous when I was a kid as
the posters I never give up and shows a
frog getting eaten by like a giant
Pelican frog seagull the cartoon picture
never get like never quit never give up
yeah come on oh okay the Frog is choking
the seagull while the seagulls trying to
see that oh that's good I metaphor so
that seagull that's life that's death
I'm getting that friend dying of yeah
AIDS whatever he's the Frog choking the
seagull out now that exact design there
with the clip art and how shitty it
looks I'm getting it tattooed on my
chest do it well because I appreciate
that never give up and I want it that's
why I brought you here and I'm gonna
never give up never give up and I'm
gonna I would like to ask now for your
audience to let me know because I want
it done free so if you've never done a
tattoo before allow my chest to be your
canvas that's not a good idea will that
be sick sighs oh you move this is how
you do the internet this is how you do
the new media get the lie to involve
everybody you got to get the like do it
for the gram bro do it for the gram
Bryan's Instagram is the only Instagram
that is a full-length television show
yeah Wow
yeah every what do we got one minute
here's one minute all right dude and no
didn't delete talked about this that it
was then fill in a minute I've heard I
had to do that one where he just sent me
that Hilaire I didn't [ __ ] see it
shut the [ __ ] up I'm racing Chris when
we we know when your audience knows of
course a specific instrument you've seen
this one
yeah I've seen all those the last one I
look more like my nose you know lore
Bubba what's getting very big in older
Bubba
your here's the frog in lies the pelican
if they give you if Instagram increased
it to two and a half minutes your videos
are between how you do 13 minutes he
would do 13 minutes he would just talk
until
and it's like you know and now I'm
heading over to and that's how they stop
because he's just talking until it ends
you're the only person who also uses the
the the camera in it and just records
right on the app and then send oh he
opens Instagram oh come on man that
talks into it bring him in there and
then he hits scent I hate being unfair
my eyes I gotta get my eyes pulled up a
little bit yeah let's I would like to
watch that some eyeballs I mean I'm not
Matt your eyebrows though bro it's the
one thing that's [ __ ] thriving I'd
like to watch this one and talk about
what sort of plastic surgery okay my
[ __ ] is eating up too much real estate
should be his next t-shirt front pockets
cuz macaque is special not I would start
with an eyelift okay and then there's a
problem area right around
the owl's there well and then I would I
would pin those ears back a bit what and
then I would definitely Botox the [ __ ]
out of that River like crease yeah I
wanna kill you a little bit of a nose
job yeah a little nip tuck on that I've
never taken a punch to the face and yet
yes boxers nose yeah I'd replace your
lips completely [ __ ] yeah I put the
powers in yeah and let's go ahead and
bring that hairline down and even it out
did and then you know looks and I'd fill
out this part here the dry working late
yeah now are you morphing into a
bloodhound I'm not happy with all belong
my face has become I'll be honest and I
understand now do you own a bloodhound
no because they say start to turn into
your dogs or to look like your dog well
you look like a damn good bloodhound
Corgi and a shepherd my face is becoming
very pointy I'm full of points I want to
call that plenty of group your face not
mad at it though your face grows like a
root vegetable no no it's got lines and
it takes its own it just sort of follows
the soil no I feel it goes character to
my face it's a distinguished face more
like character
I love funds
I love puns I love doing comedy on your
podcast and sharing some funds where
where it's s similar outer layer yeah
what's up with your shoes what is that
did the male cheerleaders it's Super
Bowl four where those those are the
Dallas Cowboy the Boosters the guys who
would shut the girls up in the air
golden better they had in the NFL up
until Super Bowl four when they realized
hey no one wants to see these guys toss
girls in the air well just have the
girls dance around pompe how do you feel
so sorry Brian you're fired
well can I keep my shoes so Super Bowl
four [ __ ] off these are expensive those
are Dallas Cowboys
all day already these are made by our
golden goose those were made in Austin
Texas in 1969 because you're them at
Super Bowl four no when you were tossing
girls in the air and holding their foot
and putting your other hand on their
fanny and they go yay
rah-rah-sis-boom-bah and you kept I did
Shirley all right I was an athlete let
me ask you this
did do you how do you feel about man men
now
cheerleading the LA Rams bring them I
live around Sept 2 and you've seen these
boys dance
I haven't they can dance I bet they
guide away I do like I will say this if
we're gonna go if everything if there's
no [ __ ] you know rules anymore and
everybody's just you know you know men
or women women are men and there's
whatever like all the good all the
[ __ ] PC [ __ ] that's going on right
now yes that easy I don't know I will
say this yeah don't make them dance
differently than the girls you want in
on this let's [ __ ] do it
I agree and as a matter of fact this to
me is sexist you really want to [ __ ]
go there make them wear the same [ __ ] I
agree don't don't be like what all the
men are doing it - because it's
everyone's the same and then make them
wear their own [ __ ]
they're not dead at all yeah I can I can
tell just by listening to them that
they're [ __ ] incredible dancers his
name is Napoleon he can [ __ ] break it
down I like it final audition only 40
people would make the cut and these men
knew they had what were they wearing do
we know what they wear at the games cuz
there's been several games now six games
I saw I get it I saw a clip chin go back
there's an actual in them dancing I
think oh there we are that one there we
go first time but three make oh that
looks like practice their outfit there
we are yeah see now you got to wear the
same [ __ ] I agree and you have to you
have to adjust so you should just go at
least one on the left hot cheerleaders
claim they endured yeah you hear about
this weed and we were body shamed they
had different rules about this
cheerleaders make zero money religion
others are fighting double standards
tied to their weight and wardrobe I feel
humiliated
okay well now it's this is a different
story now no this has nothing to do with
that I figure out what team it was was
it the Redskins were the girls they're
like they were forced to go this thing
and take their tops off like it was some
sketchy [ __ ]
yeah they I don't I don't remember the
team but they they had these uh they had
these guys against you look it up any
cheerleader
become a cheerleader for the prestige
right now for the money yeah the
prestige but $100 a game and they
practice like 20 30 doesn't make enough
money to pay them they're they're poor
yeah there's Roger Goodell make like Red
Sea million dollars a year topless photo
shoot uneasy night out you know they had
these guidelines I can't I don't know if
the skins but the the the cheerleaders
had these guidelines to where they're
not allowed to fraternize with players
but players don't have those guidelines
so basically what you had happening was
the players could you know hit on the
girls all night long but the girls would
have to leave the restaurant leave the
situation the responsibility which was
was all on them and that's unfair but
what is fair is for the male
cheerleaders to have to wear exactly
what the female chair cheerleaders are
wearing now I'm not expecting a man to
wear the bra top thing that's silly
she'd be shirtless yeah shirtless and
then I'm sure have fun and his nuts just
find out the front he's that that guy's
in [ __ ] incredible shape and he can
just wear shorts why is even in long
pants why is he in long pants
Daisy Duke I if I'm in a game and the
cheerleaders come out and I'm watching
oh look there's the she's lovely and if
you're if you're on the other side of
the fence and you're watching this guy I
don't I wouldn't want I guarantee is
because via because if the average bro
who sees that wants him in long pants
but that's not what we're saying that
we're saying doesn't want a male cheer
that sense you're gonna go down that
road I'm saying if we're doing it let's
do it yeah do it you got to go all-in
dude now there's only two right there's
no more to you that's two first Rams the
best team in football I thought there
was four altogether - there's one of the
Saints is to another team in two on the
Rams I meant just Google how many male
male cheerleaders are the NFL cracks me
up it seems to be a whole bunch of
cheerleaders I know there's no e after
our cheer jet chipped up chip no trailer
chairs joined two NFL squads only two
are featuring okay and the Saints both
good teams well nor that grinded things
to a halt
let's talk about your shoes again you're
not excited about it B so now I'm here
on your podcast
what do you been doing well yeah
interview me guest
you've been busy dude you've been doing
stuff Loudermilk
yeah litter milk what do you I do is
that shows getting some travel is it be
well our milk it's on the audience
network but it's getting traction is it
getting traction I think so the kids are
saying they seem to be are advertising
that not just don't shut up well no no
no milk where do you know what he
actually shoot at in Vancouver that's
your hometown dude how many episodes you
shoot 13 no we just shoot 10 - 10 year
actually are you done yeah I'm done
we're part of our season 2 premiere is
tonight as we record this all right well
that's why you're here now that's
trailer that season so watch this yeah
and it's wrong we don't need Rob
Livingston right you're running a
meeting at yeah run living store oh wow
I have chills from that wave of
excitement coming at me this Pete
Davidson in this dude will know of
somebody coming to my meeting let's get
the band back together and back to the
church you slip up just one that guy
played my dad on a show in the 90s that
guy yep
they're a team we play oh okay
Brian Regan I like this piece of
funniest [ __ ] dude he's got a dart
stuck in his head how deep is that in
there
do you see no one can ever hurt this is
season 2 excusing yourself every day old
something no more phones in the meeting
get sober not fans
oh that's a good quote yeah Ron's on
another show right where you can make
eyes where he commits suicide you have
friends like what yeah it's like the Big
Chill suicide all right so everybody to
you like you you like doing it right
yeah I love doing it it's Pete Farrelly
and now Bob Hurley has also joined the
joined the gym thing about Mary yeah the
early brothers Farrelly Brothers behind
it and Bobbie Mort is the fellow who
created the show filmed in your hometown
and films in Vancouver so Pete was like
you know the other year when we started
it or whatever he's like oh I really
want you to do the show and by the way
there's right available impersonation of
what pills are available anyway so yeah
Loudermilk it's a good time and there's
some sort of cliffhanger so if you're
watching tonight I'll spoil it right
here I'm not in the first episode
because we're because because I ran off
with his ex-wife at the end of the first
season and then come on you know but
watch it anyway do you make out with the
actress yes nice my good friend Lauren
nice Lauren Wasser I haven't had to do a
kissing scene and almost ever wells
really finding a kid 3d you made out
that attractive young girl I did yeah
you'll remember that's right do you see
these things right yes
do you never do you want you never do
like kissing scenes and laughs love
scenes I don't my character is so alone
in the Goldbergs he just can't get a
date and now that I'm older it's it's
gonna be even harder it's gonna be even
harder is not I nobody see me fall in
love on the screen uh I'm always the
idea I'm always doing kissing scenes you
know man I'm always married and I just
did I didn't
[ __ ] times what I'm doing Udrih
movies too right will and in movies yes
and in movies I'm always kissing in the
movies mistake hey I don't like that I
didn't mean to do don't be rude I was
just gesturing like and then hey sorry
what was the Super Troopers Super
Troopers my last movie I did not kiss
anybody in that no I did did some movies
I did to move some awesome Brian I'm
like where the [ __ ] will band he never
hit the Sun every time he's on set doing
movies do a movie God you think your bro
you actually moved out of the IB has
right I don't know
cool you should always rent your place
out in [ __ ] now give it to Brian in
Lhasa few vacuum out the bride from the
year 2000 where I'd freshly Aussie want
to wait look at my [ __ ] head oh my
god
yeah no I just shot why I shot boss
level with your with your good pals
Frank hello Carnahan right worked with
the Mel Gibson Carnahan said it's the
first movie ever where where you're in
frame and Mel Gibson is out of InFocus
yeah he did this shot Simon where a Mel
Gibson is like completely out of focus
he goes and then he's like anyway [ __ ]
now I'll give some was singing your
praises by the way oh yeah he was he was
a pretty cool in a way that's kind of a
pretty that's a good marker in your
career when Mel Gibson is talking about
good you are
that's nice yeah you know that [ __ ] Mel
Gibson that's what I say to him you know
no no my I'll I'll tell you my Mel
Gibson and iron pretty much every scene
together and so they would like
sometimes that I tell you this sometimes
break us for lunch at the same time and
my favorite thing was one day one day we
just went to lunch early so we're
sitting there talking about whatever and
there was like they were doing like you
know you know like [ __ ] steak and
[ __ ] over there and Joe has a wonderful
wonderful set up and so at any rate cut
to us sitting there and I'm like digging
into my steak and we both either the
same way really wrong how Rawls dude ah
I mean like when you go I want to blue
on the inside charred on the outside I
want it my
be on the outside let's be on the
outside lukewarm in the middle mmm
yeah it could be even a little yeah ho
like room wow do means it's pretty good
she in the middle I I want to sue she
like
like a barn fire started and it's a
thousand degrees and a cow runs in there
to save her calf real quick and get out
and then gets out and just like is
totally wrong the outside the house is
that fifth degree burns no that's too
much for will really was I think that I
wouldn't send that one back you would be
happy but me nobody happy though you
mean that might be a little too cooked
that's a little too you're you're like
that's getting there now we're talking
now we're getting there you're like
Tommy Lee Jones in under siege really
yeah and that more well that's medium
rare I like mine rare there we are that
that looks like I cooked it that looks
exactly like I cooked then he'd take it
you take it super raw in the middle
yeah you and you and Mel Gibson's the
steak that way and bonded over and he
was and he was eating it he was ripping
it apart like an animal like just just
would like rip off a piece because it
was so perfectly rare and we just saying
and we'd be talking and think and so
pretty soon I put down my fork and knife
and I'm like I got I got I got the okay
to go hand yeah I like everyone goes
[ __ ] you like when Mia briny and sushi
is it the right thing to do no but Brian
will take his [ __ ] hands and just
grab the whole thing like a bonbon and
then you start doing and it's so much
easier yeah I just pop it and I started
doing that's when you know that's when
you know you're friends with someone
when you can go and you do that eat at a
BBQ place and get [ __ ] out and get off
yeah get it everywhere what one you say
you don't know a little brisket and a
dicksuck I'm afraid I know hold on a
second now because you said I was just
saying you could get messy while eating
and then you said something you said no
you said that [ __ ] you said [ __ ] right
you said and [ __ ] afterwards and some
yes tri-tip and ass play I know that's
what you know saying don't blame it on
him don't blame anyone what did you say
I said you could I barely got it out I
said you know you can eat with your
friends you can get messy right and
that's exactly what you said I was
finishing what you're saying right do
you
I just haven't barbecue then you want to
have barking [ __ ] you know because I
heard you go and and then I so I finish
the sentence well okay alright anyway
well now this is the now it's not about
Mel Gibson in the all right okay
and then point is will you've been busy
and I did some other stuff yeah hey so
it says Three Stooges no that's fake
that's never gonna happen if you wish it
would happen uh five years ago it's a
solid movie rising well no just it's
like it's like you know I mean I'm 61
years old I can't expect it to do all
those stunts and stuff now yeah I shot
that we shot that movie in 1985 when
your kids yeah yeah I don't know anyway
yeah yeah you've been around at all dude
no I know I haven't been here all summer
I've been gone for like yeah kind of
been gone since how long you're in town
now though uh like a little while I'm
gonna go back I don't know like two
three weeks I'm going back to Canada
what why I like it there from there I'll
tell you what you know as things get I
well I've made a decision in my life
recently and coming out right now might
as well share it here and I think I
think it's a good I think it's a smart
thing for me I've decided there's a lot
of there's a lot of you sort of hard to
navigate you know what's going on and
you're the world and you know the right
seems to be pushing more right to left
seems to be pushing more left and it's
and and there's a great deal of the
country that are sort of like you know
in the middle going what I don't get
what who's who's wrong who's right and
so I've decided that it would be smart
for me to become millennial millennial
[Music]
I'm 43 after the 43 so I've got to miss
the marker there it again I was born in
1975 yeah yeah we missed the marker so
but I am I feel more like a millennial i
side I want to be and I
like I am and I feel like I have the
right to be so how does that translate
into behavior well I just basically sort
of if I'm wrong about [ __ ] it doesn't
matter okay that's one thing you can
quiz me on politics right now if you'd
like you could talk know that stormy
Daniels has to pay all of trumps legal
fees yes I did know that do you know
she's doing porn again oh I did not have
probably now cuz she's got to pay all of
trumps legal fees which is not I think
he had a team I wonder how much that is
I wonder what that's good now that's
that's oh by the way Ellie let's abandon
right millions let's abandon well
because she cuz she she I was just gonna
say let's abandon the stupid millennial
but I want to talk about this yes I want
I got you out of it do you know what I'm
saying that this is fascinating to me
because the the definitions who got
dismissed and now she's got to pay I
mean cuz she yeah this is he did sign
that non-disclosure thing so now you
know what is this now that's her how
much she was seeking 75 grand
Oh thirty thousand no that's that's the
money no that's not we probably don't
know I don't know what's gonna cost yeah
that's true that's probably not
available on the internet it's gonna be
this whole legal team I mean you're
talking at least mid-six figures sure
yeah I would assume low seven yes well
it's man you know the the input the the
implications of this decision like any
other decision recently even you know I
mean we don't need to get into it but
the whole Brett Kavanaugh of it all
there's all these other implications for
it especially in the middle of you know
the this me to movement and sort of this
you know this rift that's happening
between some women and some men although
you know I would like to think that
everyone is still of sound enough mine
to oh look at that figure their [ __ ] out
on the sketch of the guy she says came
up to him but look at that guy it's
probably the fact that he called her and
how about the fact that he called her
horse face how did the fact that that
guy that guys feel Vaughn that's
slightly asked out douchey years later
about a non-existent man a total con job
paint Wow shiz ID the thug that's what
was she thinking she's not thinking well
you know but but here's the thing it's
like it's like I don't know okay use on
portal went way up probably seeing now
that Fred told my friend oh yeah a
friend of like yeah
friend of she knows that oh you found
that out a friend
Michael have and I said there's a tape
you know and all that and this is a
warning shot it was all [ __ ] yeah
well you know look okay
alright here's what's up a turnout [ __ ]
I shouldn't even so it's like this right
[ __ ] it I'll bail on it now I'll say it
no it's okay i I don't whatever let's
not I'm not trying to pass judgment on
on stormy Daniels or [ __ ]
what's-his-face the president but you
can't they hold too much influence
people everywhere going to look at this
decision and then real and then think
you know okay well if a guy is shitty
with you you can't really talk about it
not that and that's not the case she had
sex with the president she wanted to or
Donald Trump or whatever it was a it was
an arrangement she thought she was going
to get on yeah I got paid hundred and
thirty thousand dollars a shut up to
stop talking with those those those
those NDA's are garbage
obvious to do nothing well they do
nothing until unless you want to jump
into court and now she's in in trouble
because the signatures a signature if
you if you agreed to something than a
court of law probably probably notarized
something I'm probably the winner and
he's the kind of guy who will sue he's
sooo happy and that's changing the
public you know them you know our
societal a pinion of how that works I
mean it used to be very American to to
sue someone but now it's just it's
getting out of control if you're gonna
wanna sue feel what I'm doing his friend
he does Trump likes a fight like score
two victories I feel like he scored this
victory you know with with this whole
store McDaniels thing and then he
then pen Elizabeth Warren how about
Elizabeth Warren who was it at Harvard
Law School thank you hold my hand
Elizabeth Warren who was at Harvard Law
School as a woman of color because she
was Native American but that's how she
was that's not how she got her job no no
but it just cracked me I'm talking about
you know what but the and now I'm
talking out of my ass
the fourth Native American the Cherokee
no she's one one hundred one one one
thousand less than one thousand
gentlemen but also a nation was like who
the [ __ ] do you think you are that's
true as a white woman the Cherokee
Nation and the Cherokee Nation said that
that a DNA DNA has nothing to do with
who a tribe considers a citizen of their
tribe and a DNA DNA would would would
take the would assume that someone in
South America were the same as she's one
1024 far less than the average American
now she's so full of [ __ ] you're not a
Native American
why was she saying she's Native American
well she was a woman there was something
about ascension there's something about
her being you know tied to that and
she's so full of [ __ ] that just go piss
go piss piss hard you want my jug you
could just stay here now you're your hog
isn't fitting in there ya know it's a
problem because she sort of picked a she
picked a mountain to stand on and it
didn't make much sense I shut the [ __ ]
are you ok look at you you're not Native
American but the whole point of being
like when you talk about being Native
American and what you faced or whatever
people do discriminate a lot of times on
how you look she couldn't look more
white she's whiter than anybody in my
attack that's true she's more what the
[ __ ] you talking about she's more Dutch
you know windmill and somehow in
something white would know in Holland
yeah well you know but here's the thing
and now I'm uneducated here why did she
say it to begin with native ancestry if
she just said it for some street cred
then that's a problem yeah she did yeah
well there you go that's a problem
because
cuz worse it's a problem it's
embarrassing yeah because why do you
know she talked about it she's the one I
brought it up he was like why she
brought it up you weren't yeah
and you know just just to be just prove
that you're a part of it
listen that you can I do you would know
this hey Brian you noticed let me get a
goddamn word out you know you [ __ ]
let me say what the [ __ ] is your
sentence no I'm trying to finish my
[ __ ] Center now I'm done okay but the
thing that kid correct me for on this
statement go ahead
I asked 100 women in Hollywood hot girls
hot hot girls what their what their
ethnic origins are 199 of them even if
they have super blonde hair and freckles
go um I'm actually Scottish and Native
American they all say Native American
yeah because it's something cool to be
well because it because it's because
Native American women are very pretty
there's a there's a you know there's a
lot of yeah it's a mystical magical look
I guess it's kind of crappy to say this
out loud but I kind of feel like you
know well North America in particular is
headed in the right direction you want
to talk about in a thousand years
everyone's just going to be this
beautiful creamy cannot see no mulatto
yeah yeah so you know when you got a if
you do have a woman that is I'll give a
[ __ ] what it is part something and part
something else as a man there's a new
wall there's a what there's a new flavor
at uh yogin fruits come on you know oh
you were I'm half dutch half Japanese
holy [ __ ] what are you I'm [ __ ] half
Kenyan and half Irish what the [ __ ]
that's it's hot oh here go warrants
central offense dates back to the mid
nineteen eighties when she first
formally notified law school
administrators at Harvard that her
family tree includes Native Americans
warrants here Bobby here here it is
Warren Central offense dates back to the
mid eighties when she first formally
notified law school administrators that
her family tree includes Native
Americans still on this [ __ ] Warren
she's Warren deal on Warren said she
grew up with family stories about both
grandparents
our mother's side having some Cherokee
rare blood the story was that her her
her father's family did not want her her
father to marry her mother because her
mother had a substantial amount of
Cherokee in them and so there was this
sort of this idea that it's like no you
can't be together in this Romeo and
Juliet thing now that's romantic and she
obviously heard it from her family and
she can't assume that her family was
lying to her so she took this all the
way to being you know to working at
Harbor she can be notified and I don't
know what school it was but the
administration in one of these schools I
can only assume what you are Harvard and
the University of passive see user used
her her word as her being a part Native
American to you know to include her in
the and I don't know if the term is
correct here but the affirmative action
yeah and and sort of okay well that's a
quotient of our why would you form our
minority is that do you better like that
lady in I think it's Seattle or maybe
it's Portland when she was pardoned and
double-a-c-p she was the head lady he
was white as she said she was black and
then a reporter like just a local news
guy went to interview he's like clear
that because she's her planet broke out
yeah not Rachel dozy yep yes sir and she
darkens her skin and she does that with
her hair she's actually identifies as
the black woman in the documentary when
she's like Netflix this is fascinating
yeah you feel a little sorry for it
she's also a little batshit crazy crazy
she just wants to be which brings me
back to something that we've abandoned
I'm a millennial millennial now well if
you say it I'm sort of I sorta it's the
cutoff for millennial I'm I'm millennial
you're sure as [ __ ] nut chin cat you're
a millennial yeah I think so you know
that weird reading X I don't really know
no you might be a millennial I don't
think it's 1982
yeah millennial oh [ __ ] yeah I'm a
millennial bro - dude no you're not I
jump in on this sorry okay
let's abandon so what's what's what's
cat 1995 at the cusp so what are you
guys called
xanax you guys call Gen X Gen X extreme
90s is how we do this 1999 and Brian's
50 in 1999 and will is only 15 years old
and soon they're both gonna be in
Hollywood
Brian's much older will as much younger
cuz he's a millennial P&H feel so good
Dapeng Chang medibang better dang this
is my favorite line of that whole song
all the gangbangers what are you trying
to make this it's like no they're not
gonna forget about the drive they're
done and what a great song Brian this
the first time he's ever heard what a
great Martell George on tell Jordan this
Abdul it's the nineties community for
fruit roll-ups
Lunchables and your backpack Michael
Jordan Michael Jordan and written
Gretzky and tamagotchis the Seinfeld
show
[Music]
yeah hit it for short in the wrong shots
man there and Brian let me let us
educate your old ass for a second I know
the song 93 million views this is how we
do Shannon oh na na na na children in
northern Unni
[Laughter]
ah daddy so it's fire and the kid it's a
podcast on the podcast
Brian Schuster from Super Bowl four when
he was a male cheerleader with the
Dallas Cowboys
it's hard being our beat singer than
trying to be tough too and then it's uh
it's easy when you look when he was like
six foot nine if all they said was six
eight he stood or whatever he was that
tall I've heard this song ten thousand
times because I grew up in this period
hey 20,000 dislikes who the [ __ ] put
dislike on this song 93 mom responsible
for 15,000 of those I wonder was he's
doing these days yeah I went to house
parties in 1995 so I've heard this song
non stop non stop yeah classic don't
really so jock jams yes whoo Bam Bam Bam
jock jams chin jock jams
indeed you know how old you think chin
is well we talked about this before
right 22 thank you thank you that's
right old is chalk jams what do you
Marian this stuff be John James it was
all from like Stadium songs yeah well I
play one sure cat you're way too young
for jock drugs are you here an athlete
you'd was still before games or
something
oh yeah all the songs from the stadium
yeah
whoo there it is it's just all in there
it was all these hits then shock I just
put on my CD player and go walking to
school so I get the [ __ ]
McNichols arena oh all right will ya
guys
oh yeah all right just a couple two gays
there we go it's a big bear in his
little twink there we go boys yeah yeah
oh wow
Will's shorts just yelled fun Oh for the
listeners the wheel and grind they're
fighting fighting Brian's hit him really
hard really hard and then we'll just
lift in there and he's oh you just
spiked them down and Brian hit his heel
oh no I'll make out with him oh yeah
[Music]
like you start out blocked Thanks okay
I'm Colonel Matthew some curve ends
that's called the dance break we should
do a dance break every time before we do
current events from now on here's a
little out of breath
nope I'm not know me off with Karen of
Vance now it's Friday night you picked
me up really easily dude oh yeah you
don't weigh much this was [ __ ] up this
was [ __ ] up what happened can't even
talk about it so this woman um she stood
in front of the door of her apartment
complex as a man was trying to come back
in this woman
so happened to be white the man was
black and she wouldn't let him in
eventually he got in through the door
and she kept on asking if he lived here
he said yes he's just trying to get home
and she wouldn't let him through she
followed him into the elevator asking to
see his key fob or his keys or to know
what unit he lives in he didn't want to
give her any of that information she's
crazy yeah push through went into the
elevator used his key fob to get up to
his floor she realized that she [ __ ]
up and then said I I just wanted to say
as a neighbor like I want to introduce
myself she started turning it she went
so far as to follow him to his door
watch him open up his unit go in she
called the cops and they came thirty
minutes later and what'd she say to the
cops that she felt uncomfortable what
that's what the cops came to his place
saying your neighbor feels uncomfortable
she sounds like an so what happened to
her she got fired from her job Wow
because let's get that done but she's a
goof the videos not long yeah oh it's on
giving refresh it what a dumbass she
sounds like a [ __ ] she also saw his
fob when he when he was attempting to
get in shake what you steal that I'm
glad she got fired
I'm sorry what it's fun infuriating when
you watch it
yeah it was Robert because she could say
he assaulted me I'm saying this kind of
person who's smart Ramona that's why you
have to that's why you bring your phone
out I'm just trying to get home but this
is what you want to do sometimes it's a
black Brian would you 1/1000 24th black
yes I am Rose rose look at what an ass
rose Brian he's with one gallon I'd be
hard not to just slap up you but you
better a quarter because she could say
some [ __ ] better not try to the cops and
now you get fired I'd like you dumb
[ __ ] I live here yeah I had a woman he
eaten be good for him no I had a woman
that allows a dog park screaming at me
because of my pit bull yeah and and tell
me I'd get away from me and pulling her
dogs I go hey cuckoo bird my dogs really
friendly yeah I don't want to talk to
you screaming I was like Jesus Christ
yeah well two things that has nothing to
do with this and don't have this but
what wow I was just saying that has
nothing to do all the dogs she goes you
guys you got black guys near pitbull and
I was like wow and I was second I was
like well black time cuz I'm Sicilian
and she knew who did what did she do for
her for her work she worked at a realtor
office I believe she worked managing a
apartment complex you can't have that
she showed herself being I can't well
life is one big litmus test especially
now with things just getting ramped up
and ramped up and this guy also is I I
read somewhere I don't know if he was
keenly aware of it or the you know the
it was an editorial opinion within the
the the article I was reading that he
was also worried about you know there
was this this situation that happened
not too long ago where an undercover cop
came to her home thought she was in her
own home I opened the door and there was
a black man in his home and she shot the
she was undercover she's
she shot never said she was undercover
and we could go back and listen to that
and you know nah nah didn't say that she
she was off duty he said she came home
didn't say undercover you know so she
was off duty and then shot so this guy
so I don't know again I don't know if
this is something that he said in an
interview later it doesn't matter it's
it's the truth it's this is the sort of
[ __ ] people're it's crazy that people
are deal about you not you because your
opponent
keep pushing the mic into my face it's
super disrespect you are very more
around that's four times I'm another 50
you guys you've got I bet you've got not
a 50 dude don't you I got blonde hair
like stormy day at home topper how i
dunk in your English because you're
Dutch you're [ __ ] done
mine's a Mile High Stadium my next event
it's funny how Indians 15 and Jim if we
get into any more fights you have your
brothers stealing your prize don't get
me into the well call mecklenburg bates
all kinds of aggression music just takes
all the aggression out of here Amber
Rose Amber Rose the last five-year-old
son to curse but which is he went used
the n-word
so amber Rose came out in an interview
thing that she doesn't want she doesn't
want her son to say that n-word which
got picked up from Wiz Khalifa and she
would much rather him say [ __ ] she also
goes on to say in the interview that she
wants to give him the sex talk as soon
as possible and that he will know how
babies are made before he knows that
Santa isn't real
she wants to be the type of mom that
stocks condoms in the house just in case
she's give me the cool bomb yeah like
the money there's no that kids I'm sorry
kids already know that
well lots of kids know and for years and
years parents have been saying this is
how when a mother and a father love each
other very much they get together and
they are amorous and later a baby comes
out that's how first we got South Ryan's
but well this is what you're whitey [ __ ]
parents no I'm like don't that my mom is
Sicilian yeah and everybody knows that
there's foreplay I'm gonna teach my kids
about gotta have some foreplay I
remember a good buddy of mine he was
like the first one of my friends to have
kids and so he was like whatever 22 and
yeah this is his boy his first boy and
when we were hanging out and you know
the boy was like 55 years old or
something that I said the f-word I'm
like oh sorry he goes oh I don't give a
[ __ ] you know everyone's so worried
about the [ __ ] f-word it's just
[ __ ] language who cares you know I'm
worried about him seeing and then you
know yeah
violence this or that I don't know but I
mean I think that's wise to say well
don't you know don't want you using the
n-word but you can say [ __ ] look I don't
know how any kid as a millennial I'm
speaking as a millennial here I don't
hold on I don't know how any I don't
know how any kid avoids any of this
stuff you know I was having a calm
station I don't know why I'm thinking of
this but years and years ago this guy he
wanted boob that he thought we needed
this shot of boobs in the movie I was
like we don't need that and it's like no
well it's r-rated I'm like you're you're
in the past you're thinking of like
movies in the 70s kids don't need to see
boobs on the Internet
they can see arcing ropes of jizz boobs
in a movie they can see the craziest
[ __ ] ropes and [ __ ] well you know that
you're addicted to porn don't denied
don't get so caught so I'm warning you
bro kids can you think they can't hear
the f-word but me I was naive and I grew
up in Canada and I thought you just said
arcing ropes of jizz yeah now like 25
there's a mammal and here's your animal
and there's research out there though
that there's something about not you
should allow your kids to cusser be
around the ones who shelter the kids
with cuss words there's some research I
don't know what study it was oh you mean
where kid boys get bored I think I
forget what a sex or like no no no no to
death whoa not even close
oh no I'm talking about where we're if
you like shelter your kid with not
allowed to cuss oh it's actually harms
then more than sure sure I think that
there's a lot that kids should learn on
the school you own the school ground I'm
not even joking and then parents should
be there to clean it up now you guys
have children I don't so I'm just gonna
speak out of my ass but having said that
I'm only 19 years old goes more okay but
the only thing is that kids now they say
which is what's different is that
parents not only are helicopter parents
they could call them lawn mower parents
oh no what's a lawn mower law and more
apparent is the parent that gets all rid
of all obstacles as the kids going
through life yeah talks to the teacher
makes the grades better does everything
for the kids so the kid never really had
counters and more importantly when they
get out in the world
kids have literally no unsupervised time
nowadays because nobody's afraid they're
kidnapping and everything else so back
in the day kids kind of had to figure
things out including bullies they kind
of had to figure out I'm getting bullied
but I gotta figure this [ __ ] out yeah
now it is we've created sort of a a lot
of parents have created you know there's
sort of a lawnmower effect and it's not
good for the kids that's perfect
yeah it's not good for their development
to ever tell you the story about
problems on their own ever tell you the
story about my older brother when some
kids came to the door
so I got into a bit of a tussle in
elementary school and after school these
kids come to the door like four or five
kids we're here and they might they
knocked on the door my older brother
answers the door he guy - yeah now he
was especially then he was again spelt
I'm soccer player and he goes he goes
they go we're here for William and he
goes and he could tell that they were
like you know some salty kids and he
went okay hold on a second William your
friends are here and I went outside and
he shut the door behind me and locked it
Wow and then I beat the [ __ ] at all five
then Oh thirsty what happened will I
think I kind of we had a chat with the
kids we didn't fight but you know they
just went on but I was I beat you all
for yeah I woke up in my [ __ ] hedges
I put you and I went to wrong with your
[ __ ] brother man you know he leads by
example he wants to there's a there's a
there's a Kwan to the world and he wants
me to go through the you know cuz I was
a millennial and he's like here's how
you do brother clothes now yeah we're
very the families all close everyone's
great anyway what's going on what else
you get what are here for kids to cuss
so they only have so many tools to
express when they're angry or frustrated
so they'll either scream kick or bite
hold their breath yeah when you cussed
they stopped doing that let them cuss
tell you what it's good work when I was
another thing I use it you know cuz I
grew up actually Italian I'm 100%
Italian unlike I've seen the videos on
the Instagram with your mom with my mom
no we're not were from Napoli from
southern southern Italy and the old man
yeah I got my older brother my older
sister the old man used to make wine and
there was always actually me and my
sister were watching some old old like
eight millimeter films every single
birthday of my brother and sister in the
late 60s through the 70s there was a
bottle of Johnnie Walker red on the on
the birthday table like somewhere near
the cake it was very funny year after
year
booze became demystified to me because
if I wanted some wine my dad made wine
for a little in my gin yeah there's no
ya know yeah it's very European which
you wouldn't understand unless you're in
[ __ ] Holland taser
don't say I'm Dutch he's gonna you're
gonna make me mad ik what else you know
what booze you know what you drink what
you know you're one of your choices a
careful
yeah be careful I'm gonna tell you right
now be careful I'm just saying you now
enjoy a beverage yeah now that the end
of my rope and I don't know if he's
gonna play John can you like a beer
stein yeah full of watch it watch it bro
cuz I'm telling you right now yeah I'm
telling you right now
why I'm just saying I'm just saying what
you prefer to drink yeah watch it a beer
stein okay full of hollandaise sauce
over ice made of deer blood because you
are white [ __ ] no jock jams are on there
it is don't don't push sorry
things move alright what else you guys
got there you go so this 28 year old man
went from Florida to Chicago to find his
ex-girlfriend's new boyfriend he hit him
over the head with a tire iron
and then proceeded to carve his name
into the new boyfriend's thigh cut off
his dick and threw it over the fence
Jesus did the guy die no luckily
somebody was a passerby found him called
the police as well des ambulance and he
is alive however he does have permanent
brain damage brain damage because the
tire iron yeah we weren't able to put
his penis back on we have no other so
one thing I wanted to know the only
thing it does work that way john bobbitt
John Wayne Bobbitt oh yeah I use this
thumb Thank You stump and then they
built a reservoir for the water well
that guy that guy should and I
you know being someone who's from Canada
this is what we do in Canada and I don't
know if there's been much much ballyhoo
made of this or if people know we do
have capital punishment we do have the
death penalty you know Brian I know
you'd like this yeah it's called the
polar bear death penalty what is that
it's where we take you in a
single-engine plane over to Canada's
Arctic yeah and we Chum we we Chum the
ice with some seal yeah just some seal
bits yeah and then we leave you there
yeah and you and put you on ice put you
out there you know but you're warm so
that you're gonna stay alive for a while
oh yeah the game but also it's a big
white shows up the old me sees you big
white shows up and sees you yeah demo
ads out to your iceberg which has
happened before
yeah and take you to the other iceberg
and eats yup yeah and I know that we've
not I Brian and Brendan I know not only
have you seen this footage we've
probably watched it several times right
here where the polar bear pulls a
800-pound walrus out of the water with
his jaws and turns him into something
akin to that actor with the mountain on
the game of Thrones that's right and
that's what this guy deserves it is
ready to be eaten slowly dick first by a
polar bear he's currently on bond for
$1,000,000 I've got it I will pay his
bond he's a good American why because he
is a he's a fine American why because he
his horseface girlfriend had sex with
another man and that is something that
he's alright posed to and just gonna
bail on bit i'm millennion on that so
there are some cities that are enforcing
a trick or treat age limit which is 12
yeah cuz teenagers they wear masks and
do some [ __ ] mm-hmm there are quite a
few cities who have this already in
place but nobody ever enforces does la
have it in place
I don't think LA has it in place but
this specific article cites that there
are certain residents in certain
neighborhoods that feel uncomfortable
when a six-foot-tall kicker
trick-or-treating but I mean that's like
a 13 year old Samoan kid maybe
that's true that's true but there's also
kids can't care don't carry ID you do
are you a lot of someone's yeah a lot of
Samoans I'm sorry don't say Samoans it's
just that I have friends from that well
that you are but don't say sama long you
knew a lot of jamon mmm I'm not giving
grown kids my candy I'm like did get the
[ __ ] out of here this for the kids what
are you doing go buy yourself a [ __ ]
Snickers bar how old are you there's no
way I'm giving out sandwiches and anyone
who violates this I guess I don't know
if it's necessarily a law or a policy
can be fined up to $100 and or time in
prison Jesus or they will have to pay
the legal fees or stormy Daniels Oh jail
not prison about mushroom dick but if
they're younger they're moved to
juvenile all right what else you got
speaking of Harvard I think you guys
have talked about it here or maybe Joe
Logan's talked about it but the lawsuit
against Harvard for discrimination
against asian-americans was filed
yesterday they did the same thing with
Jews in the 50 mm-hmm cuz they're
scoring so high that all harbors
becoming all Asians right no there are
barely any Asians in Harvard they
weren't London moon they weren't letting
them in and the reasons why they said it
was that they added a new criteria to
the application process which is a
one-hour interview based off of your
personality yes so they're keeping
people out based off of personality
that's their excuse kidding no but does
get to be asian-american you had to
score I think somewhere like 450 points
higher than than a black applicant yeah
we don't we don't get help from
affirmative action help it goes against
us yeah yeah they're 45 million ethnic
Chinese just an example are worldwide
and and they have done very well but
they have not had an easy time of it
they've done a personal rating score so
basically there's come in and be like
you're Asian you're not getting it yeah
mm-hmm courage and likeability UCLA
doesn't have that problem you watch you
never see lots of age
they're killing it over there cuz it's a
culture that do location [ __ ] premium
no matter what
how many Asians do you know especially I
think Chinese who play an instrument
fluently straight A's yes that's a fact
that's a fact you play the violin of the
piano fluently and you'll get straight
A's
work ethic is everything what else you
read a book about learn a classical
instrument do it puts a lot of a lot of
and they just did a study on this a lot
of emphasis on sports if you're a good
athlete you're way more likely to get in
somebody who asks better grades
yeah like that Harvard football team
there's so many of them go the NFL yeah
and the Harvard basketball team is
always in the funnel guys don't mock my
point all right man all right next
current event cult all right you're so
luck on you know cornerstone cornerstone
I'm glad I was about to bring this set
off go ahead yeah there's an older white
lady who was at a liquor store and then
some little black kid walked past her
she accused him of actually grabbing her
ass and she called the police at least
she said a nitro his backpack bumped her
that goes off um he's crying and she had
to apologize that she did a positive
hate these people get when they make
these mistakes therefore they get fired
from their jobs they can't come outside
like it's bad which is also not helpful
right for some of us just yes but you're
allowed to say sorry and I think a lot
of times in life if you [ __ ] up and you
say sorry let's just leave it at that
oh I disagree sometimes I think they
need to learn like the lady who called
the cop on the little girl selling
waters the black girl yeah some people
are [ __ ] and there's also after
shoes they buy bad no but it depends
what what what do you want do you wanted
to never be able to earn a living again
I mean some of this stuff is - no but
that be some look some people deserve a
second chance some people deserve the
polar pennant penalty correct whatever
penalty yeah and that's the scale it's
from sorry to your guts
frozen somewhere iceberg somewhere in LA
I'm sure now she's okay but that other
lay like called the cops on a little
girls down water
I failed I think that there's that's
appropriate in somebody's you know
there's not much of an [ __ ] yes a lot
of there's a lot of Karine obviously
there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] going on
nowadays and I think that all of this
can be couched under one tenant one one
way of being and I know and I'll bring
it back to what we were talking about
earlier yeah wrap us up wrap up what I'm
saying right right now wrap up the whole
but the whole thing yeah I think which
you could I think what you could say in
general to get through life and I say
this as a millennial and Canadian I'm
also an American citizen so I believe I
I'm interesting a lot of boxes which out
on a lot of autism also Native American
and I think you could couch this all
again by with this guideline don't be a
[ __ ] and I'd like to announce here that
myself Brendon and Brian will be running
for the first first time ever as a triad
for the governor of California correct
and as 3d we're excited about it and on
our and that's going to be our campaign
slogan don't be a [ __ ] and it's gonna be
called three whites who are more for you
three whites who are all three why do
you got more also for also free and also
would connote they're of course for the
whites yes yeah they're very white guy
yeah except for me because I'm actually
100% Italian mmm that's I never seen
that time as big as you check out my
cousins go see my cousin's cheater oh
and clouds
somebody somebody some of the women in
your family tree that took themselves
little R&R and Samoa and came back full
of Samoan seed because I happen to know
a little something about the sasso women
that is that they can't get enough
strange when they're in [ __ ] some oh
that's it hit the foam cocktail
[Music]
sighs now Brennan alrighty then
this is the finally kid with sad so
we're out
[Music]
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the wall shame